willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns diesmal nicht mehr mit
künstlicher intelligenz befassen wollen
oder robotik das haben wir in den
letzten drei sitzungen gemacht ich mache
einen link oben rechts reihen zur
sitzung in der wir uns mit der frage
nach der ethischen bedeutung von
autonomen waffensysteme befasst hatten
das war in der letzten sitzung
diesmal geht es jetzt eher um eine art
van groos theorie so kann man das
beschreiben fast schon eine ideologie
sagen manche manche sagen das ist eine
philosophie
der status des trans mannis muss ist
nicht ganz klar der philosophie darüber
muss man auch diskutieren
es geht um die frage wie die technik vor
allem die digitale technik den menschen
verändert und zwar nicht jetzt nicht
hier und jetzt sondern irgendwann mal
der zukunft und was da dann wenn man
diesen gedanken entwicklung zu ende
denkt konsequenz ende denkt was das dann
für folgen hat die folgen werden im
kommunismus sehr positiv angesehen dass
es auch noch ein entscheidendes merkmal
des 20 mann ismus wir gehen aber noch
genauer auf die eigentlichen
charakteristiken 1 dann haben wir jetzt
ein paar leitfragen die wir uns hier
überlegen wollen wenn wir uns mit dem
transformers muss befassen ja welche
philosophische thesen vertritt der trans
humanismus da steckt jede menge
philosophische gedanken arbeit dahinter
die wollen wir hier ein seminar
herausarbeiten dann ist ein begriff
besonders im zentrum nämlich die der
säkularität ein buch von einem bekannten
trans mannis tischen autor trägt sogar
diesen titel oder dieses wort kommt im
titel kommen denn vor
dann und das ist die eigentliche frage
die uns auch in diesem seminar
künftig soll weil es ja ein seminar über
die ethik der digitalität ist worin
besteht die ethische problematik des
trans man es muss also inwiefern ist die
überzeugende inwiefern nicht
jetzt möchte ich ihnen kurz ray kurzweil
vorstellen das ist ein auto mit dem wir
uns diese dieses sitzung befassen wollen
und der hat ein bekanntes buch
geschrieben
zum thema der singularität er hat auch
viele tolle erfindungen gemacht ganz
toll
über
maschinen für sehbehinderte menschen
hin zu
musik systemen das kurzweil music system
sind es heiße also ein wirklich
begnadeter ingenieur
und es ist nicht verwunderlich dass vor
diesem hintergrund eben auch in fragen
beschäftigt haben die durchaus ging die
philosophische richtung gehen er hat
sogar eine sogenannte singularität
university gegründet die sich genau mit
diesen problemen oder herausforderung
der singularität von der er eben ausgibt
befasst können sie mal auf wikipedia
noch ein bisschen genauer nachlesen sehr
empfehlenswert hoch interessante person
die sich technisch sehr verdient gemacht
hat
das hier ist jetzt dieses zeichen das
symbol des trans humanismus als eine
richtung auch aus wikipedia
trans mannis muss kommt von lateinisch
trans also jenseits über hinaus und
humanus menschlich eine philosophische
denkrichtung das muss man jetzt
problematisieren denke ich auf der
wikipedia recht hat das ist eine
philosophische denkrichtung ist es
einfach eine denkrichtung die die
grenzen menschlicher möglichkeiten sei
es intellektuell physisch oder psychisch
durch den einsatz technologische
verfahren erweitern will
interessen und werte der menschheit
werden als verpflichtung zur fortschritt
angesehen wie kann man also sagen es ist
vielleicht eine richtung der aufklärung
ja dass sie also die auf der gedanke der
aufklärung
ganz stark im zentrum steht eine art von
techno aufklärung willkommen zur
bewertung noch am ende dieser heutigen
sitzung
und jetzt möchte ich ihnen kurz
etwas vorstellen zum begriff der
singularität sie haben sicherlich schon
mal den begriff der singularität des
worts singularität kennengelernt
wenn es um besondere ereignisse geht es
also singularität ist ein ereignis das
eben ein besonderes ereignis ist so
etwas besonderes passiert wo wir aber
auch nicht genau wissen warum und wie
und so es geschieht nur dass da etwas
besonderes ist und
dieses wort kommt eben ganz prominent im
titel seines buches vor der singularity
ist wenn jungens translation also mit
diesen trend haben wir dem transformers
und sven transzendente heißt
unterschreiben es geht darum dass der
mensch seine eigene natur die biologie
überschreitet mit hilfe von technik das
heißt der mensch ist am ende seine
eigene biologie er bestimmt seine eigene
entwicklung seine eigene evolution
selbst unterliegt nicht mehr dem gesetz
der evolution das kann man natürlich
philosophisch interpretieren was
bedeutet ist ist eine besonders starke
form von autonomie der mensch
kann selbst sein biologisches wesen
verändern ja nicht nur sein biologisches
ändern es überhaupt seine geschichte
seine zukunft liegt in seiner hand
das ist vielleicht der radikalste
gedanke einer autonomie der vorhandene
gedanken der autonomie konsequent zu
ende führt weil viele der vorhandenen
theorie von autonomie also von selbst
gesetzgebung immer noch die schranken
des körpers der biologie mit einbeziehen
also die these vieler autonomie theorien
ist wir haben sicherlich teile an uns
oder dimensionen die in unserer hand
sind andere bereiche jedoch nicht die
betreffen unsere biologische natur und
der trans humanismus vertritt die these
auch diese biologische natur liegt in
unserer hand auch hier können wir
autonomen damit verfahren
ganz sparen die prothese und jetzt sage
ich was zum begriff der singularität
diese grafik ist diese buch entnommen
und sie sehen hier auf der x-achse ein
zeitstrahl die extrapoliert der bis ins
jahr 2100 reich
und auf die y-achse sehen sie
werte eingetragen wie die
kalkulation also rechenoperationen pro
sekunde pro dollar dass also ein
ökonomischer
effizienz faktor könnte marzahn
das sehen sie hier
und sie sehen dass diese kurve dass die
ganz klar
steil ansteigt haben dass also
exponentielles wachstum
zunächst ist die kurve recht flach sieht
aus wie lineares wachstum hier in den
20er bis 40er und
jetzt plötzlich so um das jahr 2000
herum da wird das ganze immer steiler
und im jahr
2100 vielleicht ein bisschen später wird
wenn sie die kurve weiter sich in diesem
exponentiellen wachstum denken die so
steil was schon senkrecht dass sie
eigentlich gar keine funktion mehr ist
ja bei funktion ja
differenzierter sein müssen stetig ist
sie aber nicht differenzierter sei es
gibt einen punkt wo sie eigentlich
gar keinen klaren
keine klare funktion ist kein klaren
wert mehr hat weil sie so senkrecht ist
und das ist eben diese situation der
singularität und hier irgendwo der
zukunft vielleicht 100 jahren da steigen
die rechenkapazitäten pro sekunde mit
blick auf die kosten so an da können wir
so viel rechenleistung produzieren das
etwas neues entsteht und dieses neue und
das es hier geht das wollen wir uns
genauer anschauten das als eine
interessante zukunft
spekulation kann man sagen die aber viel
für sich hart weise eben zeigen kann
in der vergangenheit lagen diese
ereignisse auch auf dieser linie
wir denken die einfach weiter und wenn
wir sie konsequent fortsetzen dann muss
irgendwann mal ein punkt erreicht sein
wo die leistung so extrem ansteigt dass
das neueste aus reagiert
und jetzt möchte ich ein bisschen was
aus seinem buch vorlesen er fragte
bordgäste singularität future period
piece of technological change or break
it is impact so die der terminbörse
transport oder youtube in audis kopien
ist epag wildführ form der kanzlei und
give me to life von business model to
the cycle
including der
also transform an ismus behauptet wie
wir auch schon gesehen haben dass die
technologie der passiv ist dass sie alle
formen die existenz betrifft an der
station vor auf julian
christain
general and water authority
carrey als einzige larita ist eine
person die
die bedeutung der singularität
erkennt also fast schon eine art von
existenz finden die die bedeutung der
technologischen entwicklung ihrer vollen
schärfe für unsere gesamte
lebenswirklichkeit erkennt vor allem
auch für unsere zukunft das ihr spiel
die zukunft noch viel stärker mit 3 das
singuläre titel repräsentiere
combination auf dem murger hatte die
verbindung die verschmelzung auf eurem
blog of thinking and existing existence
of technology usa outing in adretter das
statement bud spencers
autobiografie cruz der merino
distinction passt security and human
machine and physical and virtual reality
hier in dieser singularität da
verschmelzen verschiedene bislang
getrennt existierende formen und zur
realität zu einer neuen form das ist
diese transformation und diese
transformation die bedeutet dass wir am
ende auch unsere biologischen wurzeln
genauer gesagt unser biologischen
schranken muss man sagen
überschreitet wir werden also irgendwie
frei von uns natur und entwickeln
vielleicht eine dritte natur könnte man
sagen der die unterscheidung zwischen
zweiter natur
kultur der vernunft und der ersten natur
der biologie aufgehoben ist das ist so
die perspektive der singularität
können sie nachlesen seinem sehr
spannenden buch des security es mir als
im jahr 2005
jetzt kann man diesen transfers muss
auch noch klassifizieren zum beispiel
der trans humanismus ist spekulativ sagt
nämlich dispo-kredite with several
decades informations base technologies
dass die digitalisierung wurde und
kampagnenmanagement professions i-auto
mitglied including the pattern
recognition
problems ordnung skills in den national
intelligence auf der youtube rezept also
hier ist der begriff des musters müsste
sehr spannend und man muss kurz weil
schon recht geben in den letzten jahren
er hat das buch 2005 geschrieben hat
sich dadurch einiges getan wir haben das
gesehen und im seminar über künstliche
intelligenz nach oben rechts eins zum
thema neuronale netze
wir sehen schon das muster erkennen
extrem bedeutsam wird dass es uns eben
hilft verschiedene bereiche der
wirklichkeit neu technologisch zu
realisieren vielleicht nur zu simulieren
vielleicht sogar zu duplizieren
er geht dann auch immer wieder auf das
gedächtnis das menschliche gehirn ein
sie sehen dass anhand auch dieses buch
covers und die idee ist dass unser
gehirn was ja mehr über die
schnittstelle von
intelligenz und biologie ist das gehirn
ist dieser zwischenwelt
darum geht es in das die mit dieser
zwischenwelt des gehirns ganz
technologisch
rekonstruieren und uns mehr oder weniger
von der biologie die dem gehirn zugrunde
liegt zu einer physischen ausstattung
frei machen das ist so die perspektive
dann kann man auch dazusagen der trans
humanismus techno optimistisch und
progressiv spekulativ ist aber eben sagt
in einigen jahrzehnten ja wann genau
das heißt der nationalismus kann immer
dann noch sagen ja es ist noch nicht so
weit war hatten wir noch mal 20 jahre es
wird schon kommt das natürlich ein
problem weil wir alles in die zukunft
verlagern und können das nicht wirklich
falsifizieren das ist ja immer die das
kriterium für
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis dass wir
aussagen falsifizieren können wenn sie
sich eben wieder liegen lassen das lässt
sich der trans mannis muss nicht weil er
eben immer sagen kann ja wir müssen eben
doch noch 50 jahre warten dann kommt
aber die qualität das ist so ein
bisschen eine selbst immunisierung
strategie die ihn problematisch macht
zumindest nach dieser prägung der
traditionalismus ist techno
optimistischen progressiv er sagt
willy
use it messe parallel wann handelt will
im internet connection subotic
simultaneously
recognize sattel peters
basic
1 loher
electronics
that makes this
can't wait for process information
extreme limited compared to die
exponenten droht auf die firmen laut
space also die geschwindigkeit unseres
gehirns obwohl es sehr gut musste
erkennen kann ist sehr gering ja er
vergleicht immer die geschwindigkeit mit
der lichtgeschwindigkeit und daran misst
er den erfolg des denkens zweite mini
scientist ingenieurs have what are
scientists pessimist
in der digital district tales of
contemporary challenge mitte fehlt die
alte mit lang implications auf der burg
in der lage führt of work in which the
great wide field account for the farm
ablaufen tools
generation
also die aktuellen wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler die sind
pessimistisch
weil sie sich zu sehen ihre jeweiligen
detail probleme stricken und nicht mehr
das große ganze vorfall nicht in die
zukunft schauen sie haben nur eine
schulklasse auf sie können nur in die
nächsten monate blicken dem nächsten
jahre in fehlt der optimistische
weitblick der eben auf die singularität
team zählt und das kritisierte an der
naturwissenschaft
ja dann kann man eben noch sagen hatten
wir schon kurz angesprochen trends and
is muss trans humanismus ist
transzendent das aber auch im moment auf
einer weißen warum es singularity
villalobos zu trends and diese
limitations auf alle basketballfans
einmal g power over auf aids wir werden
unser schicksal selbst in die hand
nehmen können oma taraji be no hands to
be able to life as long as
satelliten statement vom single if a
million dead and thinking and ethics and
expand is read by the end of this entry
bei laut porsche intelligence brilliance
of queens of time warp auf denn an
erhielt human intelligence am ende
dieses jahrhunderts am ende des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts da wird
irgendwas besonderes passieren
weiteres zitat many kommentar des kombis
changes und bot depressive solo
songwriter aspect of humanity mad world
von des transition des perspektiv stamps
firma mit understanding of water
technology wohlbekannt oder maschinen
made to date lag dies angels sattelt auf
jemand bei logic qualität
security as many faces most important
application ist das technology and
environment & supplies of warcraft the
best of you may also der transformers
muss der ist sogar so humanistisch er
ist kein anti humanismus sein er ist
eben immer nennt kommunistisch als er
den gedanken der menschheit konsequent
zu ende denkt also in gedanken des
menschen der menschheit steckt dass er
oder sie selbst die technologie so weit
vorantreiben wird dass er seine oder
ihre grenzen überschreitet das ist diese
immanente gedanke des transform an ist
muss also man könnte sagen ist es
eigentlich gar keine überschreitung des
menschen und rationalismus sind eher
eine fundierung eine bewusstwerdung des
menschen in seiner eigentlichen
wirklichen bestimmung nämlich seine
eigene natur biologisch zu besprechen
jetzt haben wir hier verschiedene
evolution gebrochen als man kann sagen
dass der trans mannis muss nach
kurzweil techno geschichtlich ist als es
eigentlich eine große geschichte
erlebt nämlich verschiedene epochen an
und diese pochen die folgen eben auch
eine evolution spa roddick war und sie
bauen aufeinander auf wir haben hier die
erste epoche physik und chemie die
zweite biologie hier brennt wolf dann
haben wir neuronale strukturen
dann haben wir die technologische
evolution und jetzt wird es interessant
sagte abgebrochen fünf da verschmelzen
technologie und menschliche intelligenz
und die epoche 6 das ist dann so diese
letzte die letzte der letzte große
schritte dieser
gigantischen evolution da wird das ganze
universum
letztendlich intelligent zahlen weil wir
unsere intelligenz nicht mehr auf uns
beziehen sollen verbreiten in der ganzen
das ist eine unglaubliche utopie die er
hier entwirft natürlich hochgradig
spannend und faszinierend
ja also er sagt zur evolution evolution
ist abuses of creating patterns of
increasing oder altes carsten konze tor
vorne in der nächst chapter ihrem festen
biss action ist wann der konzept auch
per anzeige liebt das ist evolution of
parents wird konzipiert die auf story of
the world's evolution works crew in der
action it stage of users die information
auf die previews ad hoc create the next
konzepte leisten history of the ocean
lodge kontexten
sharing ins xxl proxess will discuss the
single hit i will be king of pop wird
brad von
block 6 das ist also hier die evolution
in der fünften woche hatten wie gesagt
da findet die verschmelzung von
menschliche und technologien menschliche
intelligenz statt luginger hätte die
cases cholerische will begin with
the south america auf die baskets bonn
brains liter kapazität and knowledge
sharing aperitif technology with the pop
label human machine civilization eine
jungen machines zivilisiert
zivilisation der mensch maschine
kooperation von center human brain
stimulation von mir handelt will
extremis locations sich über astra wo
kam ej goldjunge problems und bastian
klewer junge kreative team können
künstliche strukturen kann künstlich
eleganz überhaupt kreativ sein eine
spannende frage da mache ich oben rechts
ein link rhein zu ästhetik der künstlich
intelligente in meiner vorlesung vom
letzten semesters in die richters
diskutiert habe ich bin da ein bisschen
skeptisch
reserven im herbst intelligence der
evolution has been a while overcome
evangelischen south beach von evolution
securities
amplifier die aktuelle direkt und auch
das praktische creations so jetzt vors
tor erst die dritte fall sei die
eigentliche geschichte muss ersten
geschrieben werden und das ist eben eine
techno geschichte eine optimistische
pyrotechnische geschichte techno
geschichte und jetzt kommt die endphase
dieser theologischen futuro logischen
techno geschichte nämlich die epoche
sechs der university briggs ab in der
after maß auf der security intelligence
die reifen mit spikes origins human
brain science technology origins in
jungen ingenieur beginnt asset trading
und energy
archiv des bayorganizer in energy
provider optimal level of computational
das brett outsourcing
also der kerngedanke besteht darin
menschliche der gedanken menschlichen
telegent ist nicht gebunden an dem
individuellen körper der sie begrenzt
also unser denken unseren die legende so
verfasst der sie nie nur auf uns bezogen
ist und dass sie die tendenz hat sich zu
erweitern also sich zu vergrößern in
alle bereiche vorzudringen die nur
denkbar sind finde ihn sehr spannenden
gedanken bald tatsächlich das bemerken
wir das ist philosophisch relevant unser
denken hat erkennt eigentlich keine
grenzen wir können sehr viel denken wir
können auch sehr viel realisieren nur
bemerken wir häufig die grenzen unserer
realisierbarkeit sind eben unsere
zeitliche beschränkte existent und unser
körper unsere biologische natur unser
denken so diese alte geschichte die es
schon lange gibt geht zurück auf die
card der sagt unser denken lässt sich
vom körper trennen und die res kopie
tanz lässt sich davon isolieren als eine
substanz die ist eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich ja individualistisch
festzumachen langer gedanke der jetzt
hier mit mitteln der technologie
konsequent weitergedacht wird weiter wie
köln gehen das tempo speed of light also
bauen den factor of the transfer of
information so benting bis limit erst
regalen des heiles bachelor ba ta hinz
der diskont may be able to bis zu
passieren sammle ddr sensibel alte mit
lee hannes super lumino
betty blitzkrieg
die pänz
mechanismus auf die trends frontend
exquisite lisa bleibt forms of
intelligence und konzentriert bis 6 in
die wirtschaft patterns of information
security ist ja als eine wirklich
grandiose fast schon science fiction
mäßige
geschichte die hier erzählt wird die
sehr suggestiv ist und sicherlich
viele
plausibilitäten besitzt in der aktuellen
entwicklung die aber eben endlich dieses
letzten zustands der singularität
durchaus problematisch ist er spricht
auch noch davon dass die virtuelle
realität wie der realen realität
verschmilzt hier habe ich natürlich
kritisch etwas einzuwenden ich glaube
virtuelle realität ist eine form von
realität übereinstimmung ist so nicht
denkbar erscheint virtuelle realität im
sinn der simulation zu verstehen in fact
the pursuit romantik partner will be
able to select the different body for
you denn jemals elektro joseph price wo
sie also hier so die these können dann
andere körper wählen in dieser
singularität hat nur ein anderes buch
geschrieben die age of special machine
da möchte ich jetzt nur kurz darauf
eingehen hier ist der obertitel one
computers xtm intelligence das betrifft
jetzt konkret eben die künstliche
intelligenz
hier spricht er eben von der
sterblichkeit die durch unsere körper
bedingt ist er spricht mit blick auf die
zukunft darüber dass ein date airways
aber evolving mein fall ruby software
norton das ist natürlich der konkrete
gedanke wenn wir unsere biologische
natur hinter uns lassen wollen müssen
wir unsere hardware hinter uns lassen
und biologisch hardware und uns nur auf
unser gedächtnis unser gehirn
konzentrieren was und seinen augen als
software
zu denken ist was auf ganz verschiedenen
hardware basen dann realisierbar ist
eben auch nicht biologischen
hardware-basis zum beispiel aus silizium
und so weiter
also erst software modelle tu wien no
longer gependelt und das survival of des
computings circuit der
wirbelstürme hardware in paris bat die
erstens auf identität was mit switch to
the performance software also wir können
eben uns immer wieder auf neuen
technologischen basen als software
reorganisieren und behalten unsere
identität als software bei indem er den
körper seiner biologisch oder materiell
aus silikon
silizium wie auch immer neben wechseln
und das ist ein gedanke der auch schon
älter ist den gibt es bei john bock jean
lockt ein denker der frühen neuzeit eben
genau diese these vertreten hat die uns
identität besteht nicht in unserem
körper so in unserem bewusstsein das
bewusstsein kann verschiedene materielle
körper annehmen oder darauf übergehen
aber seine identität besteht eben allein
im bewusstsein um nicht in den körper
ist also ein alter gedanke schon
und hier gibt es noch eine form von
anthropologie des computers
day computers wird die pläne den anbau
des prinzen in wales aber danny in
survival ultimately bekam independent
auf der hardware bis zur wahl will audi
modelle ti wird ab diese fische blick
erfolgte mit frequenz backups also immer
schön speichern unsere identität dann
können wir sie wieder herstellen der
kerl ist dies will have to load an old
backup kopien bieten touren sind werden
sich das sofort sie haben ein
computerspiel gespielt sie haben
vergessen einen spiegel speicherstand zu
speichern dann müssen sie es noch mal
von vorne anfangen oder zumindest von
einer situation aus die sie eigentlich
schon längst überwunden haben so sagt
jetzt kurz war wird es auch mit unserem
eigenen lebens wir sehen also hier geben
computersimulation fiktion und realität
ineinander über
computer storage essentials of mines and
the bull and up extending 1 1 in serbien
integration des
bürgermeisters central european
internetportals zivilisation hier finde
ich ganz spannend dass kurz für eine
lebenswelt spricht da stimme ich ihnen
ganz zu diesen maschinen diese prozesse
vielleicht genau die werden immer mehr
teil und zur lebenswelt die frage ist
nur ob sie so teil unserer lebenswelt
werden dass sie mit uns verschmelzen das
wage ich zu bezweifeln aber musste er
noch die mensch maschine interaktion in
einer vielen themen weise dingen als auf
die weise dass wir denken die maschine
steht uns entgegen wie so ein roboter
sondern die prozesse dringend eine ganz
verschiedene bereiche aber wir sind am
ende immer noch diejenigen die diese
prozesse leiden das können wir diese
ergebnisse mal vorläufig zusammenfassen
also der trans humanismus orientiert
sich an der biologischen
evolutionstheorie sie haben diese
verschiedenen stufen gesehen aber
erweitert diese durch eine
technologische revolution story in der
technik und mensch immer mehr
konvergieren der trend zu genießen muss
ist
technologisch technologisch heißt es
läuft auf ein konkretes ziel hinaus das
ist die singularität der trans
humanismus versteht technologie als sich
normativ selbst rechtfertigen und
blendet damit ihre ethische problematik
aus der trans mannis muss ist so könnte
man sagen techno normativ das betrifft
die große frage nach dem verhältnis von
zahlen und zoll
das sei als dasjenige was ist was
existiert das ist die technik das sollen
ist das was sein soll der trans mannis
muss der kann diese trennung zwischen
seinen sollen überbrücken indem er sagt
die technik hat in sich eine triebkraft
die auf das gute hinziehen und dadurch
ist diese unterscheidung zwischen sein
und sollen im transit mannis muss
aufgehoben bei trans humanismus besitzt
spekulativen und durchaus ideologische
züge weil er eben diese negativen
aspekte ausblenden warum sollte nicht
durch die neue technische entwicklung
auch große probleme mit sich kommen er
sagt nein sie sich inhärent auf das gute
ausgerichtet diese entwicklung nämlich
auf die singularität julian nida-rümelin
mit dem wir uns im nächsten sitzung
befassen werden hat ein buch geschrieben
digitale humanismus und in diesem buch
wird der dem transformers muss vor eine
bloße silicon valley ideologie zu
vertreten wie sie eben in
diesen städten wie san francisco und an
dieser pazifikküste alle betrieben
werden bei google und so weiter dass er
also nur eine ideologie aber zum schluss
der trans mannis muss versteht personale
identität im sinne von software und
reduziert somit den menschen auf bloße
technik vielleicht würde hier der trans
man jetzt sagen technik ist nicht nur
bloße technik technik liegt in unserer
natur des menschen
insofern werden hier mensch und maschine
gar nicht gegeneinander ausgespielt
sondern die maschine ist ja selbst ein
produkt des menschen und nur eine form
seiner existenz kann man sicherlich auch
zu sehen ja das war die zusammenfassung
in der nächsten sitzung angekündigt
werden uns mit dem digitalen humanismus
vor allem von julian nida-rümelin
vertreten befassen der sich als eine
kritische reaktion auf diese sehr
starken thesen des trans humanismus
versteht und das wieder versucht rück zu
behindern und 2 janis tische praxis
und wir gehen jetzt über die diskussion
wir haben drei fragen die wir gemeinsam
diskutieren wollen wir sind inwiefern
ist kurzweil singularität these
philosophisch stichhaltig die zweite
frage inwiefern ist die singularität
these ethisch problematisch worin liegen
die moralphilosophie probleme dieser
singularität these und in welchen
ethischen verhältnis sollten unserer
meinung nach mensch und technik stehen
das ist die frage sind die fragen die
wir jetzt diskutieren wollen und ich
bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit und
bin gespannt auf die diskussion